before we say goodbye we'd like to play
a quick round-up truth or dare
okay
we have in our audience nakia nikiya hi
hey
all right what's it gonna be a truth or
a dare it's a dare for you ross
all right
okay what is it i dare you to share the
latest text you shared with a celebrity
and what did you say
okay that's fine all right um okay i i
will say i i i normally just text like
real people you know like you know us um
but i okay your crowd's fun um hold on
who's celebrity
um oh this is good you know who um
you're those friends who send you like
lol videos or sort of like not suitable
for work videos that are kind of
hilarious oh my god i like my kids aunt
jill kargman yeah yo she's good oh my
god um well my the last one i got and i
wrote back i can't tell you what i said
but was to oh
i was hoping rupaul it was room
[Applause]
what did that
do well i'm not going to share what it
was but it was hilarious
was it r rated or x-rated just the r
just the r dear that's that's it um
rupaul that's what i was hoping it was
yeah i could live vicariously through
the moment she sends good texts to rue
does yeah
well thank you nikia
um
my last text was so boring you don't
want to know what it was what was it
about i was like my cable's out um i'm
not kidding that's not a lie that was
the text and we came out all right well
thank you nikki and thank you to
everybody for choosing to spend your
time with us we make this show for you
so take it with you
[Music]